gunshots fired at moving Jets on the
tarmac at the couliacan International
Airport
on board the Aeromexico jet passengers
crouching low on the floor
[Music]
gangsters affiliated with the Sinaloa
drug cartel also shooting at a Mexican
military jet
the attack a direct retaliation for the
arrest of the gang's leader and Son of
Joaquin El Chapo Guzman ovidio
the state of Sinaloa has erupted in
chaos after Guzman's arrest the focus of
the violence appears to be in kuliacan
but three airports across the state have
been closed including the popular
tourist destination of Mazatlan where
hundreds of Canadians are currently
vacationing all in all I was we're still
having fun I don't know outside because
they blocked the roads roads the
highways are
airports got shut down to and the city
so we started reading the news and
watching news about nazatlan this
morning and yeah it's violent outside
it's chaos travel companies trying to
figure out what the immediate future of
flights to the region will be Sunwing
WestJet and swoop all offering service
to Mazatlan I personally have reached
out to the company these that are flying
there both WestJet and sunling have
flights we're waiting to hear back
Guzman was flown to Mexico City Thursday
and there is concern about the violence
spreading five days before prime
minister Justin Trudeau and U.S
President Joe Biden are set to arrive in
the national capital for the North
American Summit
the government of Canada has issued a
travel warning for Sinaloa and the U.S
state department has done the same
travel distance at level four we advise
Americans not to travel to Sinaloa as a
result Travelers on the ground in
Mazatlan have been told their flights
may leave Friday
sun wing telling passengers to check the
status of their flights before heading
to the airport Aaron MacArthur Global
News